all of one mind they held hands and
chanted at
oil the old cantonese call of
encouragement and support
then they announced their mass
resignation in protest at the government
disqualifying four of their number
a decree had come from beijing and with
it the effective end of political
opposition in hong kong
for the first time since handover in
1997.
from now on anyone they found to be a
politically incorrect or unpatriotic or
simply not likable to look at
they could just oust you the four
opposition lawmakers had already been
disqualified from running in the
postponed upcoming elections for the
legislative council
today they were dismissed from
parliament british foreign secretary
dominic robb criticized the expulsions
saying china's decision to arbitrarily
remove elected pro-democracy legislators
from their positions
represents a further assault on hong
kong's high degree of autonomy and
freedoms
under the uk china joint declaration
this campaign to harass
stifle and disqualify democratic
opposition
tarnishes china's international
reputation and undermines hong kong's
long-term stability
the chief executive carrie lam defended
the decision
and explicitly reminded legislators that
they serve two masters
hong kong and china
from now on every lawmaker who enters
such an important legislature
must shoulder their responsibility of
supporting the basic law
of the hong kong special administrative
region and being loyal to the people's
republic of china
so that we are able to found a political
system dominated by patriots
last year hong kong was rocked by huge
protests often violent
calling for greater democracy in the
area
they too chanted ad oil for month after
month
now without a legislative opposition
protest is perhaps the only opposition
that remains
but this year there have been no mass
demonstrations
coveted 19 rules have prevented large
gatherings
and the sweeping new national security
law imposed by beijing
has greatly increased the stakes for
those taking to the streets
the communist party described the
security law as a sharp sword
hanging over the city today showed there
are many different ways
to make a cut tom cheshire sky news
beijing
you